Classroom 410: That's what we were saying. Oh, no, Charles.
Classroom 410: thank you.
Classroom 410: This is my last class before fall break
Classroom 410: as well. So obviously no class on Monday. Because of that just a quick reminder. We bumped. Usually your labs are due Sunday night. We bump that to Tuesday night.
Classroom 410: to do a true fall break as well. So that's when you're gonna be performing
Classroom 410: a website database attack using SQL injection. I'll talk a little bit more about that today
Classroom 410: as well. And then we're gonna dive into security operations and have a I think, a real good lineup of some people that will be joining us both on zoom and in person.
Classroom 410: As we get into start
Classroom 410: talking more about protection and less about attacks as we move more in that direction. But today is all about attacks.
Classroom 410: So I want to start with a quick
Classroom 410: review. If you if we could go through this. So let's just do 2 quick topics I think everybody should know about. And again, when we're doing these review we could just start by
Classroom 410: if you were explaining this to a non technical person in an elevator ride. What would this look like? So who wants to give me
Classroom 410: the anatomy of a fishing or a typical attack? What does that look like in a quick description in like 30 seconds? Non technical.
Classroom 410: using the key terms hopefully that we've learned about
Classroom 410: want to jump in today.
Classroom 410: quick and dirty as you understand it, there's no wrong answers.
Classroom 410: They like get a bunch of information about people, and then do one of the like directed.
Classroom 410: like
Classroom 410: kind of adds to some people, and then, like, the user will click on that link. And then they kind of get access lateral movement to move exactly what they're looking for. Yeah. So that's typically what happens. They find a way in the network. The easiest way to get in the network still remains phishing. And we're going to talk more about phishing and the research around phishing.
Classroom 410: When we talk about protecting organizations as well. Lateral movement is the key term there, because that is what they do is bounce around the network as well. So what about ransomware at the easiest, most basic level? Yeah.
Classroom 410: yep.
Classroom 410: data with symmetric incortion, so they can undo it. But 1st makes the owner pay. Yeah. So should you always pay.
Classroom 410: No, we're gonna talk more about that when we talk about response, and I was being argumentative when I jumped on you and said, No.
Classroom 410: there is no right answer is the, and it depends on who you ask as well. So planning is a key portion of that. And then finally, Ddos, just a quick reminder, who wants to help me out here anon. When you send a lot of web traffic to a certain server to just overwhelm your team, they just slow it down. Yeah, why would I do that? It doesn't seem like I make any money off of that. Maybe like a competitor.
Classroom 410: you probably want to bring down your site or gaming. Yeah, a lot of gaming Ddos attacks a lot of nation threat Ddos attacks just for infrastructure. So it's not a quick payday per se unless you're doing it to pay somebody else.
Classroom 410: And then we talked about. We ended up talking about bug bounty programs right? Like where we can go on the dark web, and and you can see the list of 0 day attacks and the difference between 0 day and end day. 0 day means there's no Patch End day is the number of days
Classroom 410: sense of patches made made available by that organization.
Classroom 410: And then the Bug bounty program
Classroom 410: is where we left off
Classroom 410: in order to do that. So
Classroom 410: if we jump around a little bit and we look at, and we go back and and look at where we left that in terms of bug crowd, and there's a lot of them. We'll talk about another one in a second, and we go through. If you look at most companies have a bug bounty program.
Classroom 410: and this is paying hackers to hack their sites and then tell them about it. If you, in fact, you can go to capital one which we all know, and they give you a way of submitting things, for cash
Classroom 410: is a way to do that which I find fascinating, and has been going on for a while now. So I want to introduce you
Classroom 410: to to one of my friends, not literally one of my friends, but a fellow we know from Richmond that they did a Bloomberg story about about how he makes money doing this, so I am going to do a quick.
Classroom 410: You check on the sound and then let's fire this up.
Classroom 410: This is a classic Nissan skyline
Classroom 410: look like just another car.
Classroom 410: But owning one of these makes you an instant star among car enthusiasts.
Classroom 410: and this guy's so rich he owns 2 of them.
Classroom 410: He affords these luxuries not by toiling away at a 9 to 5 job like the rest of us.
Classroom 410: but by breaking into websites and getting paid for it.
Classroom 410: My name is Tommy Devos, and I'm a hacker.
Classroom 410: The businesses, Tommy Hacks are headquartered in cities like New York and San Francisco.
Classroom 410: but Tommy works out of suburban Virginia.
Classroom 410: and when I went to go see him over the summer. He was crashing at his mom's place.
Classroom 410: her kitchen doubled as his office
Classroom 410: most of the time. If I tell somebody I'm a hacker. The 1st thing they say is either really or
Classroom 410: no, you're not because real hackers don't admit that they're hackers. Do people think that you do it for bad reasons. Yeah. People like, ask me, hey? I think my boyfriend's cheating on me. Can you help me break into his phone so I can find out.
Classroom 410: But Tommy's not gonna break into your boyfriend's phone because all the hacking he does is legitimate
Classroom 410: in arrangements called bug bounty programs companies like Verizon and general motors pay him to look for security holes in their systems so they can fix them before the bad guys get in.
Classroom 410: When you find one of the ones that you know is going to be like 5 or $10,000 payout. It's just you can feel your heart racing faster. And it's just like doing drugs.
Classroom 410: I don't want to go, too, into detail on
Classroom 410: with comparison with that. It's just you get that same sort of rush
Classroom 410: for some time. Now, tech companies have employed legitimate hackers to test their systems.
Classroom 410: but over the last decade or so bug bounty hunting has become much more organized.
Classroom 410: thanks to the merchants of websites that match freelance hackers with businesses.
Classroom 410: The prize money has now gotten big enough to make this an actual career.
Classroom 410: What's the most money you've made on a bug. A single report is $20,000.
Classroom 410: What about in a single day a single day $160,000 in October of last year.
Classroom 410: and I think that only took 3 or 4 h worth of actually working. So if you were to average it out, how many hours a week. Would you say you work?
Classroom 410: 5 to 10?
Classroom 410: I did it.
Classroom 410: It's so.
Classroom 410: And and how much money have you earned over the last year this year
Classroom 410: $636,000.
Classroom 410: What do you think is the thing that makes you so good at it?
Classroom 410: Just the fact that I've been doing it for so long.
Classroom 410: I thought Tommy was going to be something like a lawyer or a doctor. Tommy was very, very smart.
Classroom 410: and he was so much ahead of everybody else in the class
Classroom 410: in our classes. You could play on the computers. When you finished all your work
Classroom 410: I'd finish my work in 10 min
Classroom 410: and then just go put on the computer.
Classroom 410: It didn't take long for Tommy to fall in love with the Internet.
Classroom 410: and one day he stumbled into a chat room where people talked about their illegal hacks.
Classroom 410: They taught him their tricks, and he started hacking for fun.
Classroom 410: The 1st time he got caught was when he was in high school.
Classroom 410: He was expelled, spent a few weeks in juvenile detention.
Classroom 410: and was ordered to stay away from computers.
Classroom 410: But he didn't listen.
Classroom 410: We got into NASA computers.
Classroom 410: the Us. Courts
Classroom 410: Department of energy.
Classroom 410: Anybody that had huge budgets that should have had secure systems but didn't.
Classroom 410: And he was caught once again.
Classroom 410: but this time as an adult.
Classroom 410: Most of these right here
Classroom 410: I got in prison.
Classroom 410: we got prison bars, the razor wire.
Classroom 410: a guard tower.
Classroom 410: I've got the word hacker on my stomach.
Classroom 410: and then va
Classroom 410: in Federal prison everything is geographical
Classroom 410: and I was from Virginia. So
Classroom 410: Tommy served a total of about 4 years behind bars. The judge told me if I get arrested for computers again and come to his court, he was going to give me life in prison.
Classroom 410: and in 2010, right before his 27th birthday he got out for good.
Classroom 410: For a long time. The only jobs Tommy could get was
Classroom 410: cooks working in restaurants. That was about it.
Classroom 410: Nobody would hire him because he was a convicted felon.
Classroom 410: but by 2016 a few bug bounty programs were up and running, and Tommy gave it a try.
Classroom 410: He explained it to his mom like this, I got to hack again.
Classroom 410: and that people were going to pay me instead of sending me to prison.
Classroom 410: She didn't believe me. She was like, Are you sure you're not going to get in trouble.
Classroom 410: He's been in trouble 3 times for this.
Classroom 410: And how am I supposed to know that he might not be tempted to do something again
Classroom 410: for most people. Bug bounty hunting is still more of a side gig than their primary source of income.
Classroom 410: You get paid only when you're the 1st to report a bug, and even those payouts don't amount to very much.
Classroom 410: On one platform called Hackerone, the vast majority have earned less than $10,000 over time.
Classroom 410: But if you're really good, you can make a lot more
Classroom 410: out of Hackerone's 500,000 contributors. Tommy's among just 6 people who've earned more than a million dollars.
Classroom 410: So if we look at Tommy's profile on after one, you can see some of the
Classroom 410: companies that he's been working with as well, which I find fascinating Verizon, the Us. Defense department, and it goes on and on about each one of these. So is this a story of a local kid gone right.
Classroom 410: I'm curious
Classroom 410: why companies would engage in this behavior and what your thoughts of of bug bounty programs. Now you kind of know the other side of things now
Classroom 410: he's probably the exception. But if you look at some of the top
Classroom 410: folks who made money on places like Hacker one etc. They have very similar storylines where they are. Black hat hackers
Classroom 410: turn to bug bounty programs to be legitimate. So why do companies do this? What do you think
Classroom 410: that's definitely helpful to have somebody like basic the bad guys on your side. So you like, know exactly what they're thinking coming up here
Classroom 410: like software challenges. Exactly. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. And I think also, although they.
Classroom 410: our formerly bad guys, based off the way he described, it seems like he's not actually like an official employee. So it's kind of like they don't have that much liability. Yeah. Why,
Classroom 410: why do you think that's a good thing not to be an official employee
Classroom 410: for him or for that? Well, both well, for him he could jump around a lot, but then I guess you don't want to expose him to your actual. Yeah. Does anybody else think that Tom needs a financial advisor? If he made a million dollars a year he's living with his mom still. But that's a different question altogether.
Classroom 410: Yeah, absolutely other thoughts about these bug bounty programs. We're going to meet another hacker, Matt, who does this a little bit differently rather than being a hired gun and looking for these bug bounty programs and just scrolling through his professional as being a professional red teamer where they contract with other organizations
Classroom 410: to hack their systems as well, probably a little bit more professional as well, and he's they've done some really neat things. So I look forward to meeting with Matt. But I just wanted to show you kind of
Classroom 410: that side of the 0 days the bug bounties, because that is the ecosystem or not? Not? When you become like a white
Classroom 410: white hat like bug value finder.
Classroom 410: do you? Does the government like flag your computer and like things you work on.
Classroom 410: probably right? Because you're so good at it. It?
Classroom 410: Do you know anything about that? Yeah.
Classroom 410: the things I could say.
Classroom 410: yeah, the government probably knows more about you, and probably anybody in here than you think they know. And in fact, when we talk about privacy, there's 3rd party companies that know everything about you, including your buying behaviors, your browsing behaviors.
Classroom 410: all. And they have this all sits together so they can sell those profiles to you. So that's what companies are doing in terms of privacy. You know. You would assume that the Government would know a lot about things and then flag certain people
Classroom 410: as well.
Classroom 410: Yeah, like, at the end of the day you got caught 3 times right?
Classroom 410: so this is this is stuff where they they? You can get caught
Classroom 410: by doing things and a lot of people that we saw
Classroom 410: on the most FBI most wanted list. The only reason they're not in prison is because they're not in a Us. Or an extraditable Us. Treated country right?
Classroom 410: So
Classroom 410: it's fascinating when you pull all these threads and see how companies are trying to protect themselves, and they're literally employing
Classroom 410: Pwc.
Classroom 410: Everywhere from Tommy. If you think about it right in order to secure their organizations, their websites, etc. So that's 0 day. That is, I think.
Classroom 410: And I'll underline this about 0 days.
Classroom 410: It's and we're going to talk about risk in this matrix. And we're going to talk about impact and probability is what really, how to measure risk.
Classroom 410: And when you think about
Classroom 410: measuring risk in those terms, you know, 0 day has a high impact, but really relatively low probability, lower probability than some of these other attacks.
Classroom 410: So all attacks are somewhere on that risk matrix as well. So having to invest in these certain things like 0 days, or social engineering, or whatever you, you don't have enough money. So you have to make bets. And you have to create a risk profile. And we'll do that in this class create a risk profile and using
Classroom 410: a risk matrix in order to do that as well. But 0 days are an interesting one for sure.
Classroom 410: As well. So we're gonna jump to what you're gonna be working on in the lab.
Classroom 410: which is SQL. Injections, and this is kind of the the easiest way to describe
Classroom 410: and SQL. Injection, and they've been around for a long time. It, I think what you're finding out is like
Classroom 410: some of this is novel and new. The AI stuff. But the rest of the tax have been around for a long time, and they're still highly problematic.
Classroom 410: These injection attacks are still highly problematic. So what they'll do is they'll go to a website.
Classroom 410: and they'll do a couple of different things with SQL. Tax is they'll try to insert text, either through that big, long string that some websites have that has some data involved with it.
Classroom 410: or they even attack
Classroom 410: the username and password functions or the login functions of different organization with code. So rather than putting in a username and password in, they'll put in something else that hopefully, the
Classroom 410: the system that it's been designed doesn't. It's hopefully for the bad guys doesn't know how to deal with.
Classroom 410: and it'll either throw off an error or you'll be get access to the database, etc. And so this is what you're gonna experience right? This malicious SQL code
Classroom 410: goes into the database
Classroom 410: and grants app grants access. So who's in database right now?
Classroom 410: We had a couple of folks in database.
Classroom 410: So what? What's SQL.
Classroom 410: Tell me
Classroom 410: easy answer to SQL.
Classroom 410: If you know what it means, it's bonus point.
Classroom 410: Okay. Your database instructor is going to be highly disappointed, Neil. So it's infrastructure. Free language essentially, is to help connect databases.
Classroom 410: be able to use that to retrieve before insights.
Classroom 410: Yeah, so it is the language on how we manipulate data and databases.
Classroom 410: It's the fundamental language that we do that the coding language. So we can do things like create databases with SQL, we can do things like manipulate data, insert rows.
Classroom 410: change rows, modify rows, delete rows. We can take 2 tables and join them together, and we can do all sorts of fancy stuff. So we get the data in the way that we need to represent it. And SQL. Is the way that you do that
Classroom 410: I'll tell you.
Classroom 410: Selling point for database as well is this is a superpower. If you're able to manipulate data, knowing. SQL, and in fact, we have a lot of grads go out from the database class. I was like. I can't tell you how helpful it's been to know a little SQL. Because that allows me to manipulate and grab data from all these different places and create really interesting reports and and things. So that's my little plug for that database class.
Classroom 410: but it also that structured query language here has some flaws in it.
Classroom 410: And the well, the the database configuration has flaws in it that allows people to input
Classroom 410: bad code to manipulate the data beyond what
Classroom 410: you intended to do. So let me give you an example here. Right? So this is a classic SQL statement.
Classroom 410: select star. So what does star mean? Neil.
Classroom 410: like every common area, is, yeah. Everything from this table
Classroom 410: where the username is one. And the password is one tool, right? So it's grabbing all the data from this user.
Classroom 410: Well.
Classroom 410: what if we instead select all from that same table. So and that's what it does when you put in
Classroom 410: the username and password
Classroom 410: what this will do in the background. It'll run that SQL. Query. You're not actually typing it as a user. You're just entering your username and password. Right?
Classroom 410: So this is, by the way, a bad setup.
Classroom 410: So rather than the username being wam. Let's change it to one or one equals one. Right? This thing right here.
Classroom 410: So that is a string within. SQL, that'll do something to the database.
Classroom 410: so it goes in, and it will will manipulate this. Select all from the one table where one or one equals one, and password is one or one equals one
Classroom 410: for that.
Classroom 410: it'll actually return and provide you access to that database
Classroom 410: because it's actually inputting that that code within the database itself brilliant. If you think about it again, be fanboy
Classroom 410: in terms of this.
Classroom 410: So it allows you to actually attack things. And this is the one of the screenshots.
Classroom 410: That allows you to kind of here is a website. And you'll see all this stuff in here is another way
Classroom 410: to attack a website
Classroom 410: because the string after the backslash is usually contains data. And if you're able to manipulate that data where user equals one union select and it has the SQL query right in the URL. You can manipulate that as well.
Classroom 410: So this is like
Classroom 410: most websites have had these basic attacks figured out.
Classroom 410: but it's still prevalent. These SQL. Attacks are still prevalent, and we'll talk a little bit about cross-site scripting which we'll get to later. Most of them have these things locked down, but it is still an attack that's out and about. So for Lab 4,
Classroom 410: you're going to be performing a website attack on Dvwa.
Classroom 410: and your goal is to hack into Dvwa, using some common SQL.
Classroom 410: Attacks as well some vulnerabilities. So it'll walk you through and say, Okay.
Classroom 410: by the way, you will not be coding. It's just copying and pasting, but you'll at least know especially people in database. Oh, I kind of understand with this SQL. Comment
Classroom 410: is saying, it's grabbing username and password information for me.
Classroom 410: Now I'm gonna manipulate it.
Classroom 410: and be able to do some things. So I look forward to you doing that lab, and we'll talk about it on Wednesday, when you come back and see how easy this stuff is to perform website attacks as well.
Classroom 410: So that's SQL injections, any questions, any questions from my database, people.
Classroom 410: or anything like that.
Classroom 410: make sense.
Classroom 410: Let's talk about the very cool ones that have just come out. AI injections
Classroom 410: into these attacks have to change one thing on these slides, or they're gonna drive me
Classroom 410: crazy.
Classroom 410: One of my slides on the template. And this is way more than you have to know
Classroom 410: as those block transitions. Every time I open it back up they all go to that block transition.
Classroom 410: and I can't think of it. So that's just me being very particular. So yeah, I feel better already. It's not doing that. So what is an AI injection? This is fascinating.
Classroom 410: So how do AI models work right now? So they train on a bunch of data
Classroom 410: right? These large language models, or what we're talking about. They train on a whole bunch of data.
Classroom 410: And the idea is they build prediction models on kind of how to formulate language based on the information that they've changed. Now, there's billions of what they call these segments, right? That they can assemble. So if you ask it a question, it's actually building a predictive model as it goes, based on your input.
Classroom 410: Well, it allows you to do some really interesting things. And one of the AI injection stories that have been floating around is, you're able to now manipulate it because the thing about generative AI is the generative part. So that means you ask it a question, and then you follow up. You follow up. You're actually generating the right answer by doing multiple rounds.
Classroom 410: Well for people who understand injections. That's a perfect vector of attack into these models.
Classroom 410: So you might be able to get out data that wasn't necessarily intended to get out, or you might be able to manipulate the AI agents
Classroom 410: in order for to do things. And this is an example that I shared with you, I think.
Classroom 410: in the very 1st class. But I want to reiterate it
Classroom 410: where
Classroom 410: car dealership spun up this AI chat bot!
Classroom 410: And it was gonna help people find cars right?
Classroom 410: Well, somebody convinced the AI chat Bot, using, like these prompt injections
Classroom 410: to sell it at Tahoe for a dollar.
Classroom 410: and then they went to court, saying, This is a contract your chat, Bot told me it was a dollar and got tied up in court for a while.
Classroom 410: because that was a legal binding contract. So now, if you see any chat box. There's always disclaimers
Classroom 410: about that. But here's the basic idea. Right
Classroom 410: is, you have the model provider. They upload that model.
Classroom 410: You have the model provider.
Classroom 410: They upload that model.
Classroom 410: So if you have chat, Gpt, or you know, pick your favorite Llm. Is, they train it, they upload the model, and then you have specific ones
Classroom 410: or different types of industries. Say, your bank right in this particular example
Classroom 410: as well.
Classroom 410: So what happens is that the attacker injects crafted input to the chat bots to convince them to release data that they shouldn't, or to convince them they to release information about other customers that they shouldn't release. So there's all these techniques now that are out there to convince these chat bots because they're connected, not only to the large language model, but to the banking database.
Classroom 410: So it's an AI injection attack is what's happening. Now, I'm not going to show you how to do this. But if you're Google away from doing this to seeing or Youtube. There's a couple of good examples. I decided not to do that because it is. I want to encourage this type of behavior, and it changes so fast these models that it might not work again. So
Classroom 410: but these are the things that are going on right now, because all the large language models are tied and manipulating data. And if you're in a bank.
Classroom 410: that's exactly what happens. So if we think about this in terms of
Classroom 410: you know, the vulnerability footprint of each one of these.
Classroom 410: you know, your AI infrastructure could be a web app could be supply chain could be account takeovers. There's all these new avenues that are literally happening right now, as they're trying to manipulate, because all they've done
Classroom 410: is that hackers are after right? Your data. That's what they're after. So laminating on a large language model on this gets it a new vector of attack to that particular data.
Classroom 410: So there's a burgeoning community. Defcon has their own AI community. Now, Defcon being the conference that talks about it
Classroom 410: about these types of attacks. So there's all sorts of adversarial examples where you go back and forth, prompt injection attacks that are out there in the wild. And then data set poisoning where they actually destroy the data membership sensitivity. There's all sorts of things.
Classroom 410: So
Classroom 410: has this ever happened?
Classroom 410: Yeah. So
Classroom 410: here's an article from a about a month ago, right? Hacker steals false plants, false memories in Chat Gpt to steal user data in perpetuity emails, documents, untrusted sources
Classroom 410: so they can plant things within models to help it steal the data information. So I'll post this article because it walks you through
Classroom 410: how this was done. But you're gonna see more and more and more of these attacks, and if you see the models released, there's more security wrapped around. In fact, Openai
Classroom 410: did a major call for rethinking security with large language models to researcher because of these types of prompt injection attacks or data manipulation attacks that are happening. So this is a wild Wild West. We've seen all sorts of different things with regards to AI, and it's because you have an application sitting on data. And that application wasn't designed with security in mind first.st
Classroom 410: And so you're having
Classroom 410: all sorts of interesting things.
Classroom 410: Questions about this. I know this is the one where I give you kind of the broad view, and the reason the broad view is like there's so much happening in this space. We could spend a week on all these different attacks. But understanding more broadly, I think, is where we're we need to be at for this
Classroom 410: questions.
Classroom 410: This makes sense. Are you all gonna start? AI hacking
Classroom 410: hopefully, not
Classroom 410: the last attack.
Classroom 410: is the one. This is the reason why you should be on a VPN. But I want to describe this attack more in full. So you talked about Vpns you talked about. Why, to use Vpns. So
Classroom 410: why does Professor Lewis have Nord on his machine
Classroom 410: either, than he's slightly paranoid?
Classroom 410: Why would I? Why why is he paying?
Classroom 410: Why is he paying? I think it's $49 a year? It's not much $49 a year for a VPN.
Classroom 410: Or anyone. Let's not make this personal.
Classroom 410: You guys have no idea, either.
Classroom 410: Let's be out. Why, why would you do that?
Classroom 410: Everything
Classroom 410: you don't know, either.
Classroom 410: The hint is on the screen. By the way, so
Classroom 410: but why why, Vpns, why is it important to do vpns anon? Thank you. So no one can like tap into.
Classroom 410: You're like connection.
Classroom 410: Tell whether it's Wi-fi or anything. It's secured like a tunnel. There's no need to break into that tunnel.
Classroom 410: So, going from his laptop to the network. For example, at Uva, it's encrypted right? So nobody can kind of see that as it goes over the wire
Classroom 410: without and there's things that are encrypted like https, is encrypted, but it's not completely end to end. It's like browser to browser
Classroom 410: type of things. But this is this is
Classroom 410: classically to prevent these man in the middle attacks. So when we think about this, it's it really is. You're preventing this. And you're trying to secure
Classroom 410: your particular line between these 2 things.
Classroom 410: So let me tell you how criminals
Classroom 410: use this.
Classroom 410: And this is proliferating like crazy. There's a couple of ways they do it. This is the most classical way that they do. It is you have a bunch of users
Classroom 410: that are connected to some sort of Wi-fi gateway. Let's say, this is at an airport
Classroom 410: or a hotel.
Classroom 410: What? Or Amtrak? Yeah, Amtrak.
Classroom 410: Well, there's 2 ways to do this right. Is the man in the middle attack
Classroom 410: actually can.
Classroom 410: because it's Wi-fi, you're broadcasting all your signal and a lot of the time it's unsecure or lower encryption. There's different types of encryption right? Wpa. Wp, 2, those types of things that they can actually easily tell what's going back and forth.
Classroom 410: The most common man in the middle attack
Classroom 410: is they'll actually spin up
Classroom 410: their own wi-fi their Wi-fi gateway. They'll name it things like free wi-fi
Classroom 410: right?
Classroom 410: And what will you do? You'll go log on to that free Wi-fi system.
Classroom 410: and it'll get you to where you need to go. But it also is monitoring everything that's in your place. This is common at public places
Classroom 410: as well. In fact, there's a Washington Post article about how to protect your data in your hotel and your airport and public spaces as well.
Classroom 410: that I helped write that talked about. This is just absolutely exploding.
Classroom 410: In terms of these public places
Classroom 410: with these men in the middle types of attacks
Classroom 410: as they're going through these these things. So this is this is an easy one
Classroom 410: like don't connect to public. Wi-fi is the easiest answer, and if you connect to public Wi-fi use a VPN
Classroom 410: for that answer, because they're waiting for you to log on to your Bank of America account, or whatever bank account, and then grabbing that information. They don't care about your taxes and other things. But they're looking for that. Yeah. So does the VPN protect you on public. Yeah, it does.
Classroom 410: It does, because it's encrypted. So what's hitting here? If I'm here and I'm going out to my banking site, I encrypted here. This is me doing a walk. Believe it or not, I encrypted here. It goes out to here. It's completely encrypted back here. It is unencrypted. What type of encryption?
Classroom 410: Yeah, there we go.
Classroom 410: and then sends it back. And this person can never hear what's in between
Classroom 410: right? Any traffic. It doesn't know where it's going to. It doesn't know anything except what the next hop is, basically in that system. So that is kind of
Classroom 410: the easiest part.
Classroom 410: Yeah. Funny, is there any ways that like hackers can bypass vpns?
Classroom 410: Yes, so there's there's a couple of ways. And Professor Lewis, tell me if if you know of any other attacks as well. One of the most common attacks actually, that's out there
Classroom 410: is that malware where people will go and they're like, I don't want to spend $49
Classroom 410: on a VPN. That's a lot of money, right? So I'll just download the free version that I can get well, bad news. The free version of VPN is malware, and it's actually not encrypting your data and actually doing a man in the middle of attack. And we've seen those things before
Classroom 410: as well. But if you're using a name brand highly rated. VPN, that's using, you know.
Classroom 410: the 1048 encryption.
Classroom 410: You need an Nsa computer or supercomputer or quantum computer to to unhack that. So it's not on. Let's be clear. We learned that there's nothing that's unhackable if you spend enough time and resource in something you can unencrypt
Classroom 410: just about everything, and especially with in the new age of supercomputing quantum computing. You can do that.
Classroom 410: But they're not gonna do that, sonny. They're not gonna spend 3 months learning your because it's just too expensive to do. What they're gonna do is they're gonna wait for actually, who doesn't use a VPN and just grab their username and password. Right?
Classroom 410: It's like the famous saying, you don't have to be faster than the bear. You just have to be faster than everybody else.
Classroom 410: Is there any other VPN attacks that you know about? Those are those most famous? Is the attack against sonic wall itself. So a major manufacturer of the devices was called Sonic wall, and their devices got compromised. So bad guys basically just compromised the devices to collect all the information flowing through them.
Classroom 410: And that's good.
Classroom 410: 4 or 5 years.
Classroom 410: Yeah.
Classroom 410: yeah, it's
Classroom 410: the airport, the airport airport hotels, those types of things they're seeing more and more. In fact, I saw another article this morning of folks who are hack youth by connecting to public Wi-fi.
Classroom 410: So it's 1 of those things. Now. VPN, it's just something everybody should do, and plus it allows you to watch Netflix. If you're abroad, so
Classroom 410: do you think that most people don't have it just because of the price or a lack of awareness. Or.
Classroom 410: yeah, I think most of this is, we're gonna talk a lot about the psychology of security in a moment.
Classroom 410: And I've studied this for the last 10 years about why people act insecure, even though they say they are secure, or why people act, throw around private information, even though they say privacy is really important to them.
Classroom 410: There's a gap between our behavior and our intentions
Classroom 410: full stop. Right? So how do you bridge those things is what we're gonna talk about. And I think this is part of it.
Classroom 410: But I also think it's it's a lack of awareness. So what's happening is like, oh, my gosh! Somebody opened up a bank account and stole my information, or Oh, my gosh! Somebody stole my credit card
Classroom 410: and started using it. And we never go and do root cause analysis and figure out, why did that happen? We're always trying to just stop that particular problem like, who's gotten their credit card? Who's gotten their credit card stolen or somebody use their account without them knowing
Classroom 410: right? It's like probably 50% of us in here.
Classroom 410: Now, who knows how that happened?
Classroom 410: Out of that
Classroom 410: 10 or so of us who knows how their credit card got stolen
Classroom 410: could be anything you could have used it over. Wi-fi could have been a skimmer at Costco, which are pretty prevalent. It could have been anything
Classroom 410: but the credit card companies, and we'll talk about this, too, have made it so. We do not care if our credit card gets stolen
Classroom 410: because they don't want to create barriers to purchases, because that decreases business. If it's harder to actually use your credit card
Classroom 410: as well. It's a wild business model. We'll talk more about it, too. When we talk about the psychology of creating security culture, which is really. And we're going to have Carrie Perlman here knock on wood from Mit, which she goes to the biggest companies in the world and say, You know.
Classroom 410: buy all the hardware you want, but unless you have a security culture. It doesn't matter.
Classroom 410: You could spend billions on securing your organization. It will not matter
Classroom 410: unless you have a culture of security.
Classroom 410: So we're going to talk a lot about culture security. Because I think that's a secret sauce that very few people talk about. Tristan. What about public Wi-fi with usernames and passwords? Is that safer?
Classroom 410: Yeah. So why couldn't I just spin up a public wi-fi with? And then I go. You know I'll make it safer. I'll just have them do this fake page that has username and passwords on it? Right?
Classroom 410: So how do you really know that it's more secure?
Classroom 410: Depends what you mean by username and password, too. Like, if you go to a coffee shop you have to like, ask person working there what the username and password? Yeah. So I could easily spin up. If you'd like me to, I'll do it in here one day without you all noticing. And you'll log on the Uva. Actually, we did that we've got. Yeah, we're not allowed to do that.
Classroom 410: Not allowed to do that. But I could easily spend something up that looks exactly like the copy. And it's using software that is literally, I downloaded that morning. And and it's not because I'm a i'm a genius programmer. I just cobble some things together, and I have a
Classroom 410: and that's why the VPN. Defeats that because I sent it, and it's like.
Classroom 410: I don't know what's. I don't know what's in that tube is a good way that anon talked about. It's like anything in that tube. I have no idea what's in it.
Classroom 410: It's encapsulating your data.
Classroom 410: And yeah, this is a good conversation. Any other questions.
Classroom 410: All right, we should get on.
Classroom 410: We should get a cut for all the Nord.
Classroom 410: a business we do just out of this class as well.
Classroom 410: So we are transitioning. This is official we're going to start talking about. We talk about attacks. Talk about the bad guys, we're talking about networks. We're going to talk at the very highest level today about starting to protect organizations. And we're going to introduce you to the cybersecurity framework
Classroom 410: which is the most popular useful tool for how organizations can protect them as well.
Classroom 410: I'm gonna also pause here and apologize
Classroom 410: on Wednesday. We're going to be talking. Our 1st step is called the secure organization.
Classroom 410: We're going to be talking about policies, procedures, and guidelines. It is not the sexiest stuff you've ever heard in your life. Understanding and doing that reading. It's like, what's the difference between a guideline and a policy is important when you're trying to create a security culture, because that's your articulation of how you get things done.
Classroom 410: So please do the reading. And I think we have a quiz, too. So that's a good reason to do the weed reading as well. But this is like the mechanisms, and the mechanism is writing down how we operate through these things. And this is what the frameworks actually allow you to do is to articulate our security
Classroom 410: profile.
Classroom 410: So one of the things that's confusing about frameworks is. There's a lot of out there. There's iso standards. There's a NIST standard that we're going to talk a lot about in here. There's Hipaa, there's Isac Csec, you know. Go on as well. EU standards, etc. A lot of them are kind of on this continuum of tactical to strategic
Classroom 410: so tactical. And then there's operations in the middle here where you have strategic like for what and why. So if you're talking about policies and you'll read this, the goal of policies
Classroom 410: is really to articulate your strategy.
Classroom 410: That's what a policy is. Articulation is strategy. And then you're using these other tools. We'll find out next Wednesday about, how do I do that operationally? And how do I do that tactically
Classroom 410: like, what are the things I need to do? So when I get when I give a new laptop out, you know.
Classroom 410: And I could say, Hey, Jesse, here's your new laptop. Here's the things that this laptop needs to do.
Classroom 410: We call that a baseline right? In order for it to be part of this organization.
Classroom 410: So these are important types of ways. The frameworks is a really good way of thinking about this.
Classroom 410: So I have a question before we start on frameworks
Classroom 410: as well.
Classroom 410: you know enough now to be dangerous, so I want to start this conversation.
Classroom 410: and I'm gonna ask you to kind of huddle up with 3 or 4 people.
Classroom 410: And I'm gonna say, congratulations. One of you in that group have just been named Ciso for
Classroom 410: an organization. Let's say, a Midsize organization.
Classroom 410: what are you going to do? The 1st 90 days now that you know how it kind of works that you know all the attacks. I'm just curious what your approach would be in your 1st 90 days of work. So I'll give you a couple of minutes to talk about it about what you think you would do in this particular role. We're going to talk about what systems do. We'll talk about best practices.
Classroom 410: But this is really where we're gonna start with discussions of frameworks about, what do we need to do to make sure we're securing our organization. So I want to start with your thoughts before we jump into that. Does that make sense
Classroom 410: all right? Huddle up with your favorite person.
Classroom 410: appoint a speaker, and then we'll just go around
Classroom 410: 3 min, just maybe 3 things you would do. Try try and land on 3 things you would do
Classroom 410: lots of questions. Yeah.
Classroom 410: you and David like 3 things. I want to hear 3 things from every group.
Classroom 410: 2 more minutes come up with 3 things that you agree on.
Classroom 410: So everybody group at at 3
Classroom 410: like 3 things that you're all gonna do. We're gonna talk about also what cisos make for big companies. You're gonna be surprised with that number is, I think.
Classroom 410: as well. Alright, I'm just gonna kind of go in random order around the room by the conversations we saw.
Classroom 410: As well. So, Carter, you seem to be in the middle of your group, probably hearing all this stuff. But give me. Just let's start with one or 2 that you thought would be a good place to start
Classroom 410: fresh after the last couple of days, when it's like
Classroom 410: implementing some sort of training program for the people, especially since you said that like fishing is kind of the best way to get into a Company's network, doing whatever you can to teach ever all the employees.
Classroom 410: Yeah, we're going to be talking about social engineering, training, security training and all those things. Because, as Professor Lewis has alluded to, I believe that is the 6th pillar of being secure. Do you have another one? Or is that
Classroom 410: just kind of like.
Classroom 410: Make sure that there's firewalls and stuff to kind of block outside block outside traffic from coming.
Classroom 410: So you would say, oh, we need to enter. We need to look at training. And we need to look
Classroom 410: at net network segmentation is what I'm hearing from you. Right? 2 pillars. Not bad, Patrick. I saw you kind of in the middle of your conversation as well. Yeah, we kind of said like, get up to speed on the current
Classroom 410: like process
Classroom 410: and, like the systems put in place, figure out like what? Which data is the most important to protect.
Classroom 410: And we also talked about like segmentation
Classroom 410: figuring out which employees have access to like that most important data,
Classroom 410: and stuff like that?
Classroom 410: good. We call that data classification when you get it. And we're gonna talk about it. Next class.
Classroom 410: critical critical things is data classification actually as well. Kyle, I saw you kind of leading your talk. You talked about identifying
Classroom 410: what we have in place. Now, whether that be all of our assets that are connected to the network. And then what's supporting those assets physically? And then what security we have in place, and try to find any major gaps and fill those first.st Yeah.
Classroom 410: that's great.
Classroom 410: Carter.
Classroom 410: for the same group. Are you in the same group. Okay.
Classroom 410: Sunny.
Classroom 410: So like what we would do, I think.
Classroom 410: meet with like a lot of the current staff. See? Like what the current processes look like.
Classroom 410: And then Rod said, he wants to hire like 9 hunters to like. Try to.
Classroom 410: He wants to immediately turn to the red team and say, Go for it right
Classroom 410: mean that was a joke, but
Classroom 410: it's not the worst idea, though. But what I was thinking was the company I worked at this summer. They restricted the use of like
Classroom 410: chat, Gpt, and like models that you can access to the Internet and rather use their own.
Classroom 410: It might have a 1 that's tailored to their company because they didn't allow the company data to go to another server.
Classroom 410: I think it was Samsung.
Classroom 410: It's another big attack. Yeah, I want to say that again. So one of the the more prevalent attacks on AI was Samsung, where their employees were using Chat Gpt to help with product innovation, which it actually does. A really good job in the creative space around
Classroom 410: the problem is is the large language model that found out about that product and was providing answers to people who are asking about new products for Samsung.
Classroom 410: Which is fascinating, right? Fascinating to do. We're jumping into the privacy angle of things. And we're going to talk about this. But I do want to add one particular story. So I teach in the Msba program up in Northern Virginia and last semester, probably around March of this time, as as you can imagine, with Chatgpt getting so hot and other things.
Classroom 410: It's kind of changed our way on how we think about cases, because if we give you a case and ask you for a write up.
Classroom 410: you throw that to chat to Bet. It's probably going to do a better job than you would have if you really, you know, when I say gives you that B plus a minus answer just about automatically.
Classroom 410: doesn't give you that a answer, because some things aren't exactly accurate.
Classroom 410: But I wanted to go is like, here's a case study. We're working on about innovation.
Classroom 410: Stick it in, stick it into chat, Gpt.
Classroom 410: and we're going to talk about the different ways of using this as a creative tool when it comes to product innovation.
Classroom 410: It was a class around product management.
Classroom 410: And so one of the students came back.
Classroom 410: and they and I could. I believe I could say this, and they worked for salesforce right? Because this is you're all working professionals.
Classroom 410: And Mark Benioff, who is the founder and chief executive officer at Salesforce, posted something to their slack channel, saying, Does anybody doing anything around the AI space? And this person, who was at Salesforce for
Classroom 410: brand new.
Classroom 410: said, Yeah, one of my professors is talking about this in terms of case study, and he goes. Send me the assignment. Send me the case study. I'd love to hear more about that. So that's Benioff's approach like, Go for it. This is awesome.
Classroom 410: Same class. A student raise their hand, and this company will remain nameless.
Classroom 410: but a very, very large company that we have all heard of. That is a tech company, said I started the assignment. I shoved it into Chat Gpt, and that that moment my manager got an email and my manager's manager got an email saying, I was using this
Classroom 410: to do my work. And I needed to stop immediately doing 2 very different approaches, right? Because of the problem
Classroom 410: that you're talking about. 2 very large tech companies take very different approaches. We're gonna talk about all this kind of privacy issue and stuff. But I wanted to
Classroom 410: kind of lean into that. That is
Classroom 410: a data security problem.
Classroom 410: Because what's our goal is securing our data for our, we're securing our data and throwing it to large language models. This new application that has access and building up our data that becomes a big issue
Classroom 410: as well. So that goes along with the AI injection attacks.
Classroom 410: Was that a sidebar. Hopefully, it was it was meeting. Yeah. So what's
Classroom 410: what's the rationale for not using like the same kind of system that we have before pilot? It's like a close circle.
Classroom 410: It doesn't share your what? You feed it. Yeah, at the time there wasn't very many closed circuit systems. So now there's more and more.
Classroom 410: and this large company now has their very own same sort of closed circuit system where it doesn't learn on your particular data. Here's the struggle for me as somebody who leans into innovation
Classroom 410: as well. I think the beauty of large language models is that they do learn, and by shutting off the feature of their learning. From what we're doing.
Classroom 410: you're actually losing a large portion of the ability and capabilities of that large language model.
Classroom 410: Because then it's stagnant, all based on what you trained it
Classroom 410: I don't know. 3 years ago, 2 years ago, because they take about a year to train
Classroom 410: as well rather than it learning?
Classroom 410: With your particular data or other particular data. So there is that trade off between. I'm not going to learn with any data, or I'll just learn with data within the organization. I'll learn from all data, all trade offs and risks that keep people like Professor Lewis up at night.
Classroom 410: as we've been thinking about these things long and hard. Right?
Classroom 410: All right.
Classroom 410: 1st 90 days
Classroom 410: go for it.
Classroom 410: I mean, we just talked about 3 main things. One was to do with access control. I mean it initiate initially started with identifying what they have within the organization and then
Classroom 410: coming up with
Classroom 410: finding the gap similar to what Kyle's group discussed. But yeah, access control, probably using something like multi factor authentications on all devices, making sure that's prevalent.
Classroom 410: And 3, rd was having a contingency plan in case things went South to ensure that
Classroom 410: people are trained on it and
Classroom 410: response right?
Classroom 410: Oh, by the way, there's a deal, too. You all are not ever allowed to show anybody the videos of this class, because they'll think your instructor is a 3rd grader, which, as Professor Lewis will tell you. This is as good as it gets even with a pen. So
Classroom 410: Mfa is what I heard attended, etc. Let's jump over here real quickly.
Classroom 410: Yeah.
Classroom 410: we also talked about having a response plan and
Classroom 410: a lot of stuff other people have said at this point. But we talked about patching and having, like automatic
Classroom 410: like updates being done to make sure everything's
Classroom 410: yeah. Patching is hard, though. Right? Let's all be clear about that. Patching is really really hard, because it breaks something just about all the time.
Classroom 410: As well. What about you guys, Alex? We kind of talked about like least privilege. So I guess that kind of goes along with access control, and then also, like
Classroom 410: main mainly with the top one, like training on like social engineering.
Classroom 410: because that seems to be like the most like effective way to get into helping system right? And you're and you're pandering to your your instructor, too, because, you know, he's gonna talk about that that way. Good call.
Classroom 410: good call as well. Marley.
Classroom 410: One thing that we talked about that's like, not really up there is just making it really clear to employees that if they do do something wrong, like click on a link or something, it's okay. But just like, tell the company about it. And like, that's actually a good thing.
Classroom 410: Oh, my gosh, this is getting ridiculous! I call that site safety.
Classroom 410: We'll talk more about that as well.
Classroom 410: Alex.
Classroom 410: a lot of what was said already. We also talked about having adequate backups. So if your data is compromised, it's not the end of the world. Yeah. And then
Classroom 410: also knowing kind of the expected data flows of the company. Just so you can make sure you have adequate bandwidth in the event of like a Ddos attack something like that. I call that kind of identifying who you are. Is there any group on here that have mentioned something that isn't really showing up on this.
Classroom 410: whatever this is.
Classroom 410: Yeah. We kind of talked also about like making like change, like password policies to be like, Hey, you don't need to update like every year. And like, make sure that, like, you have like longer characters and like, make it worse and make it simpler. Yeah.
Classroom 410: we also kind of talked about like understanding the business and like
Classroom 410: the processes of the business that are like vital to its functioning. And also like.
Classroom 410: maybe like understanding. If the company like posts, a public website.
Classroom 410: Good! Good! Good Tristan. Congratulations
Classroom 410: say that against encryption, encryption.
Classroom 410: gonna tear up again.
Classroom 410: I love this pandering. It's good.
Classroom 410: it says, encryption, believe or not, just
Classroom 410: as well. Anything else that you thought that was really important. Yeah, Aisha. Oh, I don't know if it's on here. But like, if the company is using like existing like Saas services, or like different vendors like, Come in and see.
Classroom 410: Friday is a real good option to have.
Classroom 410: I'm gonna call that again, identifying what you have right? Probably safe vendor consolidation among like your security tools. So reevaluating your network security cloud security endpoint security. Yeah. And you have to know it's there in order to reevaluate it. So you'd probably start with id right?
Classroom 410: As well. So one of the things about this exercise that you'll see is like there are so many different approaches like, how do we organize this in a way, what we know exactly how to roll these things out, what to do. First, st what to do. Second, because there's so much to do is kind of the point
Classroom 410: here. There's. And there's so many things that are important. And it's contextual for your organization.
Classroom 410: So we want to or introduce you to a way of organizing these thoughts
Classroom 410: in securing your particular team. Now, is it all the ways?
Classroom 410: No, but it is a good way of of thinking about how we secure things. So fun fact about this. When Professor Lewis and I were teaching this particular framework
Classroom 410: for a master's class, we actually had one of the authors in the class to talk about it, and we used to call it the NIST framework all the time, and they're like no, no, no, nobody calls it the NIST framework. Everybody calls it the cybersecurity framework. So this is what we'll call it from now on. The cybersecurity framework
Classroom 410: is what the NIST framework is, and this for those who don't know is a standards body by the
Classroom 410: that is not entirely controlled, but supported by the Us. Government in in the Department of Commerce.
Classroom 410: and they do things like weights and measures, and they'll all sorts of these types of standards.
Classroom 410: This has been around for close to 15 years, was just refreshed. Actually, this February
Classroom 410: is the most latest 2 point o version of the NIST framework. Oh, then I just broke everything.
Classroom 410: Didn't like that, Professor Lewis.
Classroom 410: There we go.
Classroom 410: I'm not gonna go back to my laptop. You're gonna have to believe me that it was the the framework was launched. 2 point. Oh, was launched
Classroom 410: in February of this year. I want to walk you through this real quickly where you were. Gonna get sick of talking about this, because it's something that everything we talk about kind of ties up into this. So there's
Classroom 410: 5 tenants to this, and they're somewhat in order. And how we prioritize. It's identify, protect, detect, respond, recover. These are all the critical functions for everybody in a cyber security organization.
Classroom 410: And then within these there's subgroups within every single one of these. And in fact, there's sub subgroups, and there's sub subgroups in these we just want for the purposes of this class
Classroom 410: is the ability to say, I know what these 5 are, and I know what the what the subgroups are for each one of these 5, basically
Classroom 410: because we do everything
Classroom 410: test wise, rather open book. This is a reference, not a memorization technique. Right?
Classroom 410: But this is the things. And I gave you a couple of readings about frameworks on what this actually means. So a lot of people said, we need to identify first, st right? And that's absolutely right. First, st
Classroom 410: asset management. Believe it or not is the 1st tool in your toolbox when it comes to managing your cyber security function and your technology function, by the way.
Classroom 410: and probably personnel in general.
Classroom 410: do you? It's like the 1st thing that anybody does new to an organization is figure out what's in the organization.
Classroom 410: And there's all sorts of interesting asset management tools that are out there
Classroom 410: understanding the business environment you talked about already governance, risk assessment. We're going to be talking about how to do Ratc risk assessments and risk strategy management. Because that's a big part of it. We literally can't protect everything 100%. So we make choices and they're informed choices. And we know what the outcome of those choices
Classroom 410: are. Gonna be. So that's the identified asset management, business environment governance.
Classroom 410: And that's when we talk about policies, guidelines, those types of things in next class
Classroom 410: risk assets and risk management strategy.
Classroom 410: Right?
Classroom 410: So what is asset management? This is literally passive. Scanning your network to see what's on your network.
Classroom 410: So going out using network sniffers for good rather than for bad, to figure out what's actually on. So this is a
Classroom 410: passive scan that says everything that's on this particular network. What kind of machines they are, etc. for that. So figuring it out so just because you think you know what everything's on your network, you actually don't know. So you're using tools to test these things.
Classroom 410: And there's a lot of free, interesting tools here, where you can go
Classroom 410: and figure out exactly where it is, exactly what it's called the operating system. On it, the browser on it, how it's patched all these sophisticated asset management tools. Do you know the tool we use? I know we use a different local one than the university uses? Right.
Classroom 410: I know I'm forgetting what it is. We use case here.
Classroom 410: Dell case, right? Oh, okay.
Classroom 410: again.
Classroom 410: Yeah. So we used to use a dell product which is now its own company
Classroom 410: and it. And it does this type of thing where it does a lot of inventory management which is critical. And, by the way.
Classroom 410: In some cases it's part of Federal law to understand kind of control your assets, for example, I'm going to a conference overseas if I take my last. If I take my laptop, there are export control laws now about taking technology overseas.
Classroom 410: and there are baselines on things like you need to have an encrypted file in order for it to go overseas. Things like that that are that are keeping that organizations need to adhere to.
Classroom 410: So protect is a second one. Access control training and awareness. We'll talk about all this data security, maintenance, protective technologies as well. You already talked about some of these. This is just examples.
Classroom 410: We've talked about a lot of these access controls.
Classroom 410: What is the how do we manage access controls is file access control lists, right permissions, list, least privileges, this type of thing. But this is now organizing all these things that we've talked about into a framework where we can now and then network control. So not only have file level access, we have network level access. Those are 2 different things. Can I access the network? And can I access a file or 2 different things?
Classroom 410: Right?
Classroom 410: And then data security security like how we do this types of stuff again, more examples and then protective technologies.
Classroom 410: What's an example of a protective technology?
Classroom 410: A VPN, right? We're right back to where this where this is as well as a protective technology. And I'll tell you in the framework how to roll these out or how to use different intrusion detecting systems, those types of things as well.
Classroom 410: firewalls.
Classroom 410: etc.
Classroom 410: So I'm going through this quickly. But again, I promise we're gonna dig into this especially around. Respond and recover.
Classroom 410: we detect. So this is the intrusion detection systems. This is the monitoring, controlling. This is looking for anomalies and events. This is what crowdstrike does very, very well. But this is the type of things where you have protection by Ids. And this tells you exactly how this should be set up, and the best practices to do this. This is this is your playbook as a security professional? Is the this standard? As well
Classroom 410: respond? The last 3rd of the class
Classroom 410: is, respond and recover.
Classroom 410: How do you do that
Classroom 410: now? What Carrie's going to come in here and tell you is one of the main tenants for understanding to respond and recover because we're all going to have to do. This is practice. So we're going to practice, respond, and recover. We're going to put you through a whole bunch of scenarios. And you're going to tell me how you respond and recover as an organization.
Classroom 410: not how the network is gonna be recovered. But how does the organization
Classroom 410: be recovered? Which is a business problem that should be solved by business students
Classroom 410: as well. So response, planning, communications, analysis, mitigation, improvements are all things that are really important to us. That response planning is coming soon
Classroom 410: and then recovery planning. So now that we've responded, now that we've okay, we've kind of quelled. We got the bad guys out, whatever that might be. What's our recovery planning? How do we improve, and what is the communication that we need to do as an organization to maintain our brand.
Classroom 410: This in a nutshell. These 5, these 5 topics identify, protect, detect, respond.
Classroom 410: and recover
Classroom 410: is everything you need to know in this class.
Classroom 410: wrapped up in this class. This framework is a brilliant, in my opinion, a brilliant organization of these topics. As we go through
Classroom 410: any questions about
Classroom 410: these frameworks before I just introduce you real quickly to 2 things and then let you go.
Classroom 410: Does that make sense like? Soon as you see it? You go. Yeah, yeah, of course. Why didn't you start with this Ryan like this doesn't make any sense
Classroom 410: it's hard to start with it when you don't know the stuff that's in it. Now that you know the stuff that's in it, we can organize it, and now we can use it to help us solve problems.
Classroom 410: They have a lot of playbooks out there. Mitre. Does anybody heard of Mitre before?
Classroom 410: Yeah. Fascinating organization. I have a reading on mitre attack. What Mitre has done is taken this framework concept and said, There, there is 364 different ways that bad guys are currently attacking your organization.
Classroom 410: Here's how they're organized and thought of in terms of what their attack chains are. So that's called mitre attack. So just click on that. And you're going to see. There's a whole way. And remember the 4 phases. Is them probing 1st them gaining access them, moving around the networks and them exfiltrating. It tells you all about those things. So you're going to see bits and pieces of this.
Classroom 410: But we're gonna lean hard into the cyber security framework from this. That's what I'll call. I'll do the from this. So there's no
Classroom 410: the
Classroom 410: confusion as well. Right?
Classroom 410: So, by the way, Mitre is the one that publishes the cbe
Classroom 410: database as well with all these common vulnerabilities and and exploitations.
Classroom 410: So that is in a nutshell your tax
Classroom 410: broadly.
Classroom 410: The bad guys
Classroom 410: broadly all the technical things again, broadly. And now we're going to be talking about the transitioning into organizational resilience. And we're going to be practicing response from here on out. So you can use all these tools that you did in a way that it's safe where you, if you, if you make wrong choices. You're not going to get fired from your job. We're all going to learn together from this. Does that sound good?
Classroom 410: So a lot of the cases are gonna be, what would you do? And you have all the information?
Classroom 410: But you have to make some decisions on, what would you do? By the way, and our experience, even with the latest chat models. They do not do a great job of responding. They'll tell you what the framework says, but not how to
Classroom 410: make choices or anything like that. So can I see the grad groups very briefly, Ivan, that have a great fall break. If I could be of help at all. Please do reach out. And what do we got in next class right.